[Aplausos]
[Música]
y él
él
hace 100 años en 1917 la revolución rusa
se llevó por delante al imperio zarista
tras más de tres siglos rigiendo por la
fuerza de los destinos de rusia la
dinastía de los romanov fue reemplazada
de forma sangrienta por cierto por el
régimen de la rusia soviética el embrión
de lo que poco después se convirtió en
la unión soviética
[Música]
y claro que eso no significó
precisamente más libertad para el pueblo
ruso pero insisto en este vídeo no vamos
a hablar de historia sino de presente de
lo que algunos ven ya como el resurgir
de una nueva rusia zarista ahora bien
realmente podemos hablar del resurgir de
una especie de rusia zarista os parece
exagerado decir tal cosa veámoslo por
cierto un apunte relacionado con todo
esto vamos a ver también en este vídeo
cuál es la forma más rápida para hacerse
rico muy rico multimillonario y no
tranquilos ni me he vuelto loco ni vamos
a hacer ninguna especie de anuncio raro
luego veréis por qué digo todo esto
[Aplausos]
un nuevo zar
hace 18 años el 31 de diciembre de 1999
un desconocido vladimir putin se
convirtió en el presidente de rusia en
2018 casi con total seguridad
putin ganará las elecciones y será
elegido presidente por otro período de
seis años así que cuando termine su
siguiente mandato en 2024 decida
continuar al frente de rusia o no lo
cierto es que putin habrá dirigido los
destinos de este país durante 25 años
este es un periodo de tiempo mayor que
el de muchos reinados de los zares en la
historia de este gigantesco país pero no
sólo eso si algo podemos decir ya hoy es
lo mucho que ha cambiado rusia desde que
putin llegó al poder y sobre todo el
particular esquema el sistema de poder
que ha establecido un sistema amigos que
recuerda mucho al de la vieja rusia de
los zares pero eso sí ha alineado con un
poquito de la receta soviética fijaos
por un lado en el nuevo régimen de
vladimir putin se han restaurado dos de
los pilares fundamentales de la antigua
urss
anda y la represión el kremlin responde
con represión a las mayores protestas en
años en rusia el pasado 13 de junio de
2017 decenas de miles de personas
marcharon en manifestaciones contra la
corrupción en toda rusia 1500 personas
fueron arrestadas entre ellas el líder
de la oposición
alexéi navalni así es con putin al
frente de rusia podemos decir que los
servicios secretos y la policía política
lo que venía a ser la antigua cajeme y
que hoy son conocidos como servicio
federal de seguridad han resucitado
junto a ello una de las primeras cosas
que hice este presidente tras llegar al
poder fue tomar la televisión a
asegurarse el control de los medios de
comunicación y poner en marcha una
potente campaña de exaltación patriótica
cuyo objetivo era algo así como decir
hey putin está aquí la rusia milenaria
vuelve a ser grande pero vale si
consideramos que el uso de la propaganda
y la represión es una herencia
fundamentalmente soviética porque
hablamos de un nuevo zar pues en parte
por haber recobrado la estrecha alianza
e iglesia ortodoxa pero sobre todo
porque putin ha consolidado un estado
controlado por una gran olga que
recuerda mucho al modelo feudal o al de
monarquía aristocracia de los tiempos
del zar veréis putin ha sabido rodearse
de un grupo de amigos a los que les ha
dado el control de las grandes empresas
del país y les ha hecho de oro recordáis
cuando antes os comentaba que en este
vídeo íbamos a ver la forma más rápida
para hacerse multimillonario pues esta
es precisamente la fórmula hacerse amigo
de vladimir putin no me creéis pues
atentos tenemos el caso de ser gay rol
de un amigo de la infancia de putin que
ha recibido cerca de dos mil millones de
dólares en fondos estatales hablamos
también de personas muy cercanas como
igor setchin antiguo jefe de gabinete de
putin
alexei miller antiguo colaborador y
asesor de putin o de sergei chémezov
antiguo amigo de la calle de hoy todos
ellos son multimillonarios y presidentes
de las más
y empresas públicas del país gazprom
rosneft y rost no está mal verdad pero
no penséis que son casos aislados para
nada los ejemplos se cuentan por
montones
timoshenko rothenberg kovalchuk a madoff
si decididamente podemos decir que a los
amigos de putin no les va nada mal no es
raro verles por ejemplo aparecer en la
lista de forbes entre los más ricos del
mundo y no solo son ellos como ya son
multimillonarios y se han hecho mayores
le están pasando el testigo a sus hijos
así que hoy es normal ver como muchas de
las grandes empresas públicas de rusia
que por cierto se han multiplicado desde
que putin llegó al kremlin están
dirigidas por los hijos de 25 30 y 35
años del entorno de putin
[Música]
[Aplausos]
fijaos por ejemplo en el caso de nicolás
amado amigo de putin por supuesto
multimillonario y sus dos hijos uno yuri
se convirtió muy pronto en el presidente
de garzón uno de los fondos de pensiones
más importantes de rusia el otro kiril a
los 25 años ya era el vicepresidente de
ciboure una gran compañía petroquímica
controlada por el gobierno ruso por
cierto este chico kiril poco después se
casó con la hija de putin y sabéis que
hoy es considerado el joven más rico de
rusia su fortuna supera los mil millones
de dólares el propio primer ministro
dimitri medvedev ha sido acusado de
haberse hecho multimillonario y de tener
palacios y viñedos por todo el país en
la descripción
os dejo por cierto el enlace al
documental que sacó toda esta historia a
la luz ahora bien puede que te estés
preguntando todo esto porque es acaso
porque tú tienes un tipo muy generoso
pues lo sea o no esa no es la intención
en absoluto que persigue al hacer de oro
a su círculo cercano
con esta estrategia putin se ha
garantizado el control de prácticamente
todos los resortes de poder del estado
él y su camarilla lo controlan todo la
factura por supuesto corre a cargo de
los ciudadanos rusos bien oligarquía
represión religión propaganda control
completo del estado y de todos los
resquicios económicos y políticos de la
sociedad rusa estos son amigos los
ingredientes principales del régimen
político moderado por este particular
nuevo zar de rusia por cierto a veces en
los comentarios nos habéis preguntado
por qué tenemos una opinión tan poco
favorable del presidente de rusia pues
bien estos que hemos visto son
principalmente los motivos fijaos más
allá de posturas ideológicas en estas
palabras de owen jones un conocido
activista de izquierdas del que casi
podríamos decir que es el indio rejón
británico
putin es un líder autoritario de
derechas que ataca las libertades
civiles y discrimina a las lesbianas
gays bisexuales y transgénero se recrea
en el nacionalismo más chovinista
con los oligarcas más rapaces y que es
admirado por la extrema derecha europea
y estadounidense rusia está en manos de
un régimen oligárquico expansionista y
que vulnera los derechos humanos el
pueblo ruso y sus vecinos se merecen un
gobierno mejor pero llegados a este
punto y visto el caso de rusia puede que
os estáis haciendo una pregunta y fuera
cuánto poder tiene realmente vladimir
putin en el mundo pues bien como nos
contó alberto en un pasado vídeo sobre
china podemos entender el poder como la
influencia y podemos distinguir entre
tres ramas militar económica y política
el resurgir de un titán vladimir putin
ha convertido a rusia en uno de los
países que más esfuerzos realizan en su
ejército muy por encima de eeuu o china
fijaos por ejemplo en este gráfico
mientras que eeuu destina a su ejército
aproximadamente un 9% del presupuesto
del gobierno y china- en torno al 6 el
caso de rusia se dispara por encima del
15% y es que amigos si tras la caída de
la unión soviética en los 90 la imagen
habitual de las fuerzas armadas rusas
era la de barcos que se oxidaban a
aviones que no podían volar y oficiales
que vaciaban los arsenales para vender
armas en el mercado negro hoy las cosas
son muy diferentes
[Música]
desde su llegada al poder y sobre todo a
partir de 2008 putin ha fijado como una
clara prioridad modernizar el ejército
así que en los últimos años se han
gastado decenas y decenas y decenas de
miles de millones en convertir al viejo
ejército en una fuerza de combate
moderna ágil y sobre todo con una gran
potencia de fuego aviones misiles buques
tanques todo está siendo objeto de
renovación
presta atención tan solo en 2015 según
datos del ministerio de defensa ruso la
armada recibió cuatro barcos cuatro
submarinos 52 embarcaciones auxiliares
27 aeronaves y 45 unidades de armamento
de artillería ahora bien no penséis que
está todo hecho para nada más allá de la
propaganda del propio gobierno ruso y
sus canales de comunicación un ex
general de los eeuu me dijo que un único
grupo de portaaviones de los eeuu podría
destruir a toda la marina de guerra rusa
ya que el equipo que utilizan está
anticuado y su tecnología obsoleta en
cualquier caso podemos decir que el
ejército ruso se ha convertido en el
referente clave de la política
internacional de moscú y no sólo por su
capacidad para influir sobre otros
países y conflictos internacionales sino
también por la renovada capacidad de la
industria armamentística rusa para
vender en el extranjero sí amigos si a
todo esto le añadimos su arsenal nuclear
queda claro que rusia todavía cuenta
y es de barro ahora bien si podemos
considerar al ejército ruso como una
baza para vladimir putin la desastrosa
economía rusa es con toda seguridad su
gran debilidad mira amigos rusia es
básicamente un productor y un exportador
de recursos naturales su economía no
tiene nada que ver con la china por
ejemplo a lo largo de las últimas
décadas no ha conseguido ni
diversificarse ni desarrollar una
economía productiva y compleja para nada
rusia cada vez es más dependiente de sus
recursos naturales de tal forma que
cuando los precios de estos productos
están altos todo va viento en popa pero
cuando caen aquí en visual política ya
vimos los problemas a los que rusia se
enfrentó con la caída de los precios del
petróleo os dejo el enlace también en la
descripción pues bien en esta línea
atentos a las palabras de barack obama
en su última rueda de prensa como
presidente rusia es un país más pequeño
es un país más débil su economía no
produce nada que nadie quiera comprar
excepto el petróleo y el gas y las armas
no innovan y todo esto tiene una
explicación
que el estado oligárquico creado por
putin tiene mucho que ver mirad desde el
año 2005 el peso del estado de la
economía ha pasado del 35% al 70% todo
este proceso ha estado determinado por
la creación de empresas públicas
dirigidas por los amiguetes de putin y
claro en este contexto sobre la
corrupción y no hay ni competencia ni
incentivos para hacer las cosas bien por
eso los pronósticos sobre la economía
rusa suelen ser bastante pobres
por cierto en 2016 más de 400.000
personas 400.000 emigraron del país
especialmente los jóvenes bien
cualificados en fin no aparece amigos
que el modelo económico de la rusia de
putin sea capaz de propiciar el
crecimiento y el desarrollo que el país
necesita y además pensarlo bien en sí
mismo esto supone una debilidad muy muy
importante una pobre economía reduce el
interés de rusia para el resto de
actores mundiales y por tanto su
influencia una pobre economía conllevará
tarde o temprano el declive paulatino de
las capacidades militares del país que
es la última gran baza de influencia que
le queda moscú respecto a la tercera
rama del poder político podemos hablar
de los últimos movimientos con china de
la estrategia rusa en oriente medio
donde moscú quiso dar el relevo al
mismísimo washington pero creo amigos
que todo esto lo dejaremos para otro
vídeo así que ya sabes no olvides
suscribirte a visual político por cierto
qué opinión tienes tú de vladimir putin
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta
esto sí el vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvides darle a like un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]